tutti ragazzi che questo nuovo video
sono fa vj condizioni in un nuovo blog
di nuovo a casa che è bello io ho
iniziato a far video qui quindi questa
camera qua rimarrà storica faremo un
museo un giorno quaden siccome sono
tornato a casa ragazzi ora incontrato
anche i miei amici fa vj nascosti
nell'armadio
[Musica]
vabbè vabbè ragazzi la cosa strana è che
quando sono tornata a casa praticamente
quando ho raggiunto i 2 milioni di
iscritti la mia partner di youtube mi
aveva fatto la torta praticamente mi
doveva inviata a casa mia solo che in un
cero e il pacco è questo quello aperto
stamattina perché stupendo ancora
mangiata tra l'altro ed è qualcosa di
[__] a me non si vede perché sono che
sto per fare un torti cidio e c'è una
lettera tra l'altro ciao a fare i
complimenti per il raggiungimento dei 2
milioni di iscritti grazie cari questa
portata regaliamo per il tuo traguardo
tanti auguri grazie ragazzi ps non devi
mangiarla ma in un blog devi schiacci
kart in faccia a gregg grazie dell'idea
però la preferisco mangiarla che buona
non faccio queste cose se pro grazie
molto gentile prima di cominciare
ragazzi cosa e dei particolare a
settimana che questo
3 buona mia madre mi ammazzerà pochi a
mia madre mi ammazzerà questa cosa me la
posso garantire o faccio il log domani
io lo faccio così quindi [__]
siamo la parte a settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da chiara che ha
fatto sto disegno mega galattico che è
bellissimo quindi grazie chiara direi
che possiamo passare alle news ragazzi
allora la news più importante che sono
tornato finalmente a casa e la seconda
news ragazzo e che domani non usciranno
più vivo in assoluto perché mia madre mi
ammazza però quella è una storia che non
centra un'altra rubin di ragazzi e con
immenso piacere che voglio ricominciare
per adesso poi non so per quanto che non
l'ho scartato dei parchi che erano ormai
da secoli che non facevo quindi gli
ultimi pacchi che ho aperto da luthi
volta che sono stato qui risalgono a
circa nove mesi fa prima quindi quasi un
anno ci sono dei pacchi che hanno un
anno quindi non ho idea di che cosa
possa trovarci dentro visto che un anno
che sono lì però vediamo
minchia quanto pesano ce n'è uno che
pesa una tonnellata e mezza ma lo apro
per ultimo perché minchia alla ragazza
ho trovato del favite ha dato il fatto
che sto pacco a un anno sarà scaduto 20
volte sa rapisce però grazie perché
sempre meglio della torta dei coriandoli
tanto camera mia non è per niente in
disordine quindi posso usarli
tranquillamente
ecco un frisbee zio mi hai preso per un
cane o cose il cubo di rubik non ha
veramente devo mettere in mostra le mie
capacità incredibili con questa cosa
[Musica]
potrei quasi sembrare un intellettuale
ragazzi se non avessi 13 chili di uova
in faccia uno spiderman da infilare nel
dito spero nel dite non da altre parti
e come odio madonna checa cosa c'è qua
dentro il berlusconi è una roba alla
madonna
allora ragazzi cos'è devono per forza
fare i pupazzi che si accoppiano per i
bambini non è massimo sta roba
i compiti delle vacanze e grazie te li
faccio subito se avete i compiti da fare
ma mandatemi nick che li faccio io che i
ragazzi cè un parco nel pacco
grandissimo o è utile mettere un parco
dentro il bacco per fa vj il pacco
contiene cose interessanti prova a
indovinare voglio la sorpresa
marghe ma gates fascia gray mi ha
inviato una bozza e il profumo di sasha
grey o e la tetta di sasha grey me ne
vado in giamaica ma è un pacco fornite
che cazzo di problemi ai fratello guarda
che io io queste cose non le faccio lo
faccio con le torte abbiamo dei degli
enta i tanti invalidi troppi hentai
mastai
dopodiché ragazzo questa è la cosa più
sexy che abbia mai visto
gli header scrolls skyrim questo trovate
in via che ci vorrà tanto ma sono sicuro
che non sia usato quella fare che ma in
via bene per concludere c'è un altro
pacco nel pacco nel pacco con joystick
un altro joystick e passato dal porno a
queste cose
una carta di non ci credo silvio
berlusconi aveva detto prima ho
azzeccato che dentro un pacco di 60 kg
c'era questa dal peso no al seccato per
concludere ragazzi c'è una maschera
fiero non mi sento proprio pulitissimo
questa roba dei ragazzi dopo questo
scart aggio che credo che sia il più
strano che abbia mai fatto in tutta la
mia vita non poteva capitarmi 1 scartato
normale mentre tornava
questo viene vi passa per fare risponde
la prima domanda arriva da serena a
cannes accorpa gli risponde ti sei
accorto che non indossi pica per i
cappelli persona non indossasse i primi
i capelli infatti non solo capendo dove
sono andati a finire perché non li metti
più sono passato dai cappelli alle torte
quindi amica mia e peggio te lo posso
assicurare ha oramai risponde chiama il
numero chiamiamo non mettete i vostri
numeri su internet però questo qua lo
chiamò perché voglio capire quanta
riattaccato ma richiama sono fa bill
gates quindi devo parlare con ciao
allora come stai e iago vera grande
storia
hai accennato di giocare a blackburn ma
secondo me non hai manco finito il
tutorial dalla difficoltà amico mio
quando farai questo boss di blood board
senza che lui ti tocchi anche solo una
volta pieni me lo dire
potrei passare per un pro ma ho sempre
13 chili di uovo spalmati fa facevano
ragazzi prima di concludere vi dovevo
rispondere alla domanda che mi ha dato
no che io avevo fatto a voi il secondo
voi che cosa significa il tatuaggio
quello che ho sul braccio il bla bla ciò
lascio io cinese gen se lo guardi mi
avete dato un miliardo e mezzo di
disposte entrata tutta quanta è una elle
poi questa qua è una elle questa qui è
questo qua è un 7 che sarebbe la mia
data di nascita che ci hanno azzeccato
alcune poi tutti insieme una elle della
madonna prova non era semplice ma molti
di voi hanno azzeccato e non pensavo
sinceramente non pensavo verità che una
torta per la vi invio oppure vi regalo
anche quello non so chi è la fai lamenta
di oggi e non mi incazzo lo dico a mia
madre spiegare poi come lo spiega mia
madre anche di disse cose cioè va beh
mia madre mi ucciderà quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia che sotto il video
lasciate un commento qui sotto con
qualcosa perché è successo di tutto in
sei minuti con la sento seguito è
piaciuto lasciato argomento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook con i
video tra tale iscrizione
se avessi discrete ci vediamo al
prossimo video della ragazzi io ho tolto
un sacco di robot prima era era ceroni
pezzettoni che erano così
[Musica]
[Applauso]